اعلنت الشرطه البريطانيه ان تحقيقاتها في
هجمات نوتينيوم التي وقعت امس الثلاثاء لا
تزال في مراحلها الاولى انه ما يزال يتعين
عليها تحديد الدوافع الحقيقيه وراء الهجوم
ياتي هذا بينما كشفت شرطه المدينه عن
هويات الضحايا الذين قتلوا اثناء الهجمات
وكانت الشرطه اعتقلت اعتقلت شخصا لم تكشف
عن تفاصيل
والهويته سوى انه يبلغ من العمر واحدا
وثلاثين عاما
معلم من المراسل الجزيره اسال الله اسال
الله مرحبا بك معنا اذا رغم ان التحقيقات
في بدايتها حسب الاعلان لكن ما الذي كشف
حتى اللحظه حول مجمل الحادث
نعم محمد نحن الان في نوت جنب القرب من
المكان الذي وقعت فيه حادثه الطعنه الاولى
خلفي كما ترى هذا الضبط يحرس المنزل الذي
يعني تم اقتحامه امس من قبل الشرطه والذي
قيل انه كان على صله بالهجوم لم تكشف
الشرطه بعد تفاصيل هذه الصله بين هذا
المنزل
والهجمات الثلاثه التي وقعت الشرطه كشفت
قبل قليل تفاصيل عن الضحيه الثالثه صاحب
الشاحنه التي استخدمت في عمليه الدهس الذي
طعنه المهاجم وسرقه شاحنته ثم حاول بها
دهسه ثلاثه اشخاص هذا هذه الضحيه صاحب
الشاحنه هو شخص في منتصف الستينيات من
العمر وكان يعمل في مدرسه وليس كما قيل
سابقا هو في الخمسينيات من العمر الضحيه
الاخرين هم
طالبات او طالبان في جامعه نوتن الاول
ياتي من جنوب غرب انجلترا في التاسعه عشره
من عمره والثانيه هي تاتي من جنوب شرق
انجلترا منطقه وهي ايضا في التاسعه عشره
من عمرها بعض المعلومات التي بدات تتسرب
الى وسائل الاعلام عن المشابه به المحتجز
هذا لدى الشرطه تشير الى انه اولا في
الحاديه او الثلاثين من عمره ثانيا هو من
اصول افريقيه ثالثا هو ليس مواطنا
بريطانيا بل هو يحصل او متحصل على حق
الاقامه عفوا الاقامه الشرعيه في بريطانيا
وسائل الاعلام تتحدث ايضا عن انه له تاريخ
من الاضطراب العقلي ولكن ليس له اي سجل
جنائيه في الماضي هناك تفصيله اخرى ايضا
حتى الان لم تعلن الشرطه محمد اي صله
للارهاب بهذه الهجمات ومن المعلوم ان
عناصر شرطه مكافحه الارهاب تشارك في
التحقيقات وهذه نقطه هامه للغايه هم لا
يقودون التحقيقات ولكنهم يشاركون فيها
وهذا يعني ان الشرطه حتى الان لم تجد اي
رابط للارهاب بهذه الهجمات الثلاثه شكرا
جزيلا لك اسعد الله